hello there reject nation all of us are
dead episode 6 reaction today that's the
devil's number hit the like button if
you uh support all religions or none of
them also subscribe and click that
notification bell to join our cult
lastly thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
but real lastly full-length watch longs
we've seen with the time crew over on
our patreon page check out all the crap
we gotta over there hey let's do this
now light the sos on fire
that's hard to act
oh my god
[Music]
oh i'd almost forgotten you
what a great storage room yeah she got
food and supplies she gets access to all
the soda
and musical instruments
[Music]
guys everyone could hear your
conversation you guys should be tripping
out by the way
[Laughter]
nice cds for the win
[Music]
okay so really they are like part zombie
for sure
[Laughter]
now you have like 70 minutes left on
that cd
oh my god
still holding strong with that cone
[Applause]
i'm cosplaying is that guy
you kids gotta learn to kill me
yeah but if they alert him
you can alert the others yeah
[Music]
now what are you guys going to drop
something aren't you you going to drop
that thermos
yep
damn
he just missed him
oh no don't turn off the no
dammit
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
get his other eye
[Music]
he's got strength
yeah i
knew it
[ __ ]
wow i liked her yeah
[ __ ]
come on maybe
oh man
maybe she'll be a
a new zombie
i really liked her
oh
stepping up
my dude
the zombies are relentless
how many other kids you could have
killed off
at least a couple sitting around doing
not much
oh he's gonna make a break for it isn't
he
it's cool to know they filmed this
during the pandemic yeah pretty
accomplishment
seriously for the amount of crowding
hundreds
of for the action hero [ __ ] about to
steal your costume right now
i gotta make sure my daughter doesn't
get into seoul university
um
he spoke to me
[Laughter]
that's why you're such a good character
oh
no she's gonna take her own life isn't
she maybe she'll live through it
need how they brought the term dialogue
back
called her by her name
[Music]
[Music]
whoa oh
oh damn she's got the good virus
[Music]
but you're like so necessary because you
are like the cornerstone of this team
oh you're so exposed
look around you
[Laughter]
oh no
[Music]
oh no jeez
back to square wood yeah
small colony of children maybe get an
old person in there
[Music]
oh jesus christ
no
damn korean child actors can act their
asses off
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
i should do anything to avoid
well
sometimes these skills just pop open
don't they yep
oh he's out can't take him
dude
maybe grab that gun
oh my god how does that badass not
believe in his daughter i don't know
i just got you as a dad jesus
you're just gonna get in more trouble
when they find you yeah you could turn
this around for yourself yeah
oh
um
oh my god dude
guys stop wasting your time don't don't
go don't die my dude
oh no no no no no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
come on man
[Music]
and our boy just don't get to say
anything
[ __ ]
yeah oh
oh boy
i [ __ ] broke the [ __ ] out of me
oh boy
oh that was uh
as a military better i'm [ __ ]
terrible yes thank god but thank god
they're terrible of all things i'll
allow goddamn stormtroopers to ease the
big attention it is that oh it's so bad
you can't shoot [ __ ] look at the guy
he's running in a straight line i know
he's not even zagging man come on
hey you know they got him under water
with one
they're all 58 you're fire in the water
anywhere everywhere he's everywhere he
is the ocean do we have any missiles we
could launch
how about a grenade we can just throw in
there it's too good can we get a nuke in
here
how many more resources can we get on
this one human man the 55 year old man
is moving too fast
yeah that's the past that's that's that
same adrenaline that helps you lift a
car when your kid's under it just keeps
you running and impervious to
bad
[Laughter]
scary looking masked up dudes
it's all their first day on the job are
they are they so relentless
we can't let anyone escape the court
especially one of ours who appears to
have been already checked out
we can't just go i guess he's crazy let
him go
we gotta get everybody we have on this
it's one guy if he is a zombie we'll
affect everything
oh yes
it's it's better safe than sorry yeah
jesus wow
that was uh
i feel like so much happened to the
episode
i know
i know it was weird it's like it's the
it it's not the longest but it's still
so substantial
they fought queen up in this one right
yeah yeah that was the episode
the last episode of this one
no that was this episode i know it feels
like we've been so many places
and yeah this isn't one of the longest
ones but it was like heavy on
like
not that they all haven't had some level
of like hefty emotional [ __ ] to deal
with but i feel like this one had like
more of that plus all of the like really
intense like oh god please you know like
don't let guinom murder this guy our our
buddy whose name escapes me now or don't
let him get shot under water while
they're all recording their goodbyes
don't let uh
uh
uh chung sun like
totally
like start a mutiny right now against
his friend like geez
yeah i think that's why this episode
felt a little bit longer in a good way
because it they let a lot of scenes
really just um like kind of relish the
tension between the characters and the
debates they were having yeah like i
really like the scene a lot when um
they're
you know i call him stud muffin because
i don't know how to say his name but
are all like in debate over what
happened because they have they haven't
made privy to anything of what's going
on with this
special virus or or the adaptation of
the virus
and um
so that that whole scene i'm like damn
what a really well fleshed out debate
because we're like none of them are
wrong at all
it's very fragile how we must proceed
given that fact and then even as the
audience though you're like but i don't
really know what's gonna happen to her
either like
she might like when she got bit i'm like
[ __ ] she's gonna be a zombie and clearly
i mean she's she's obviously been
affected by it and she's
probably at the same stage as
oh god i feel bad that we know the girl
with the suicide oh tennessee and uh
the green on yeah she's obviously at the
same level of whatever this virus is at
what they call it jojo
uh yeah whatever whatever that stage of
the virus is at
it holy [ __ ]
oh no oh no oh my god
[Laughter]
anyway whatever zombie episode
i want to comment below if there's a
jojo zombie episode yeah whatever stage
the virus is currently at without that
so
that uh that was clearly affecting her
but yeah the way they they handled the
it does such a great job at playing on
both of their stories because they all
were telling the truth and as the
audience we don't fully grasp it so
we're like is she gonna just have a
nosebleed is she gonna start
you know like to really twitching out
here
is she also gonna just be she could
become like a
a regular zombie or she become a zombie
like them so you know part of you is
like uh yeah maybe she should die but
also maybe just wait to find out she
should die yeah like contain her
someplace and observe
and they do have the benefit of existing
in a world where zombie movies exist
where
they could say [ __ ] like
hey in movies sometimes people are
immune so maybe that's the case but
that's not exactly the case
yeah it's something yeah yeah yeah
actually humbry as they call it
yeah and then bully square game girls is
locked in the closet there
which is
her timing on every time she was about
to open that door it's like why don't
they keep bringing me up every time i
want it yeah why did they keep bringing
up something i did talk about me yongsan
are they keeping her going soon every
time
crap every time she's like
oh damn it yeah oh damn it
just push and pull but that was that was
an intense one
that was a really it was really great
one and you know to have a couple of
episodes where the students were not the
most
uh exciting part of the episode to bring
it back to them were their adventure of
having to sneak off figure out the whole
thing with the music
you would think that the prez would have
probably put that together before by
being in broadcasting class
and spending so much time in the room
with the broadcasting board yeah yeah
for sure or maybe she didn't realize
that the
whatever the speaker is that grants you
access to the school allowed you to do
that intercom yeah maybe maybe she
didn't realize they had that
connectivity there or whatever the pa
speaker yeah and i mean it's easy to
forget because we're on episode six but
like it's only been a day and a half
right
we're only fast like the first night so
or they said i go crazy after five hours
two days or something maybe but yeah
it's only been
it'll be that thing it must have been
days actually it's only been 20 minutes
no they're pretty much just doing
intermittent fasting yeah you know
they'll come out all a lot more spell
they won't be able to give that one guy
crap anymore
because every time he tries to help out
they're always like your body man no
ah that's that scene where they were
talking to the camera man that should
start breaking the [ __ ] out of me
like that and them just losing hope
and saying their goodbyes but then
having that bitter sweetness with the
guys i was just like this is that was
really touching and uh
really heartbreaking yeah and i'm like
god that [ __ ] chunk suit doesn't has
no idea his mom's dead or maybe she got
the special errors
only hope she got the special it would
be nice if she got the special virus
although i think she did i mean if i
were to make a prediction
and i don't like going down the rabbit
hole of predictions too much when it
comes to shows
um especially once we're watching so
consecutively back to back where the
whole thing has been released yeah if i
were to make a prediction it would be
that
he would find his mom and then she might
bite him
ouch uh all right have you seen the show
we're watching
i think do you know what country the
show's frozen yeah
she's gonna bite him in the restaurant
over the deep fryer
like next to a big mural of his face
yeah
i either either that or it's gonna come
down to him and stud muffin
together somehow
and he's gonna have to kill stud loving
or some [ __ ]
nah i don't
i think what we're gonna get the girl
who's who's uh
she's she's gotta kill um
yeah let's not go downstrike behold too
much
um let's i like being a little bit more
in the moment with this guinom's going
to win the queen
yeah he'll cut to five years later he's
the prime minister
it's gonna be that uh he's gonna be that
leader zombie from army of the dead
yeah he's gonna have and then uh maybe
prez can be his queen
there you go all dressed up like a
showgirl i really like her character a
lot when she got bit i was like
minorly devastated at that moment
because she's she's such a strong
character
yeah when she got bit and i was
wondering that too during their fight
when uh stud muffin and and guinea were
fighting of wait a minute
can we not infect you with a with a bite
yeah and during that scene i was just
waiting for it i was like there's gonna
be a moment
where either to be a dick about it or
just because it's his only option he
will bite somebody and and i love that
they're on top of the yeah weird
mutation going there too
and i thought like because i thought the
the internal narration of guinom when
he's when he is being bitten by zombies
and is saying i'll kill you i'll kill
you like i thought that was a little a
little cheesy and and had been a bit
unnecessary in the last episode
like
i know that
of course that's what he's thinking yeah
like yeah he could even say it couldn't
he um so i i i thought it was like a
little unnecessary but then to bring
that motif back for her because she for
uh namra when because she's saying her
name's namra right i believe so when
she's saying
yeah like if if i suspect anything about
me i'll just kill myself or i'll leave
like she's tried to communicate that in
the moment yeah but it's just in her
head yeah yeah i thought was that oh
that's really strong so suddenly i like
appreciated something i didn't quite get
like well like i said in the last
episode during the review it's every
once in a while there's like a little
moment i don't really care about
and uh or i don't really like and like
they're so minor that was one of the
minor things i didn't really care for in
the last episode was that choice and
that but then to see it complemented
here where it serves a the character the
story in the moment
i thought was really powerful but it was
really effective to to use that so like
yeah it was a little
those little touches yeah these guys are
just classroom hopping there's a
classroom horse yeah yeah we gotta get
to every single place
at this point we can't go to the roof
until we've hit up every major place
we've got to go to the arrow gym just to
make sure we stamp that off our passport
but also the way they you know utilize
the the teen drama [ __ ] with the the
romantic
um
intertwinings
good work could have said that much
better and i'm gonna use the real word
i think that counts as a word
um
but the way they they use that you know
the romance is because um
what is the [ __ ] word i was looking
for oh my god i called break the mind
and her intertwine links in
entertainment
twice inter
play and turd
the way they are intertwining with each
other is how entanglements is that the
word it's better yeah entanglements is
the better thing yeah
um but yeah the because
it could it does a show like this with a
setup like this could get too bogged
down where i could sit here and go guys
let's put this [ __ ] to the side all
right you gotta focus on surviving and
getting out of here yeah yeah yeah but
they what how they utilize it is in such
unspoken moments and
and little looks and
exchanges and that's how they complicate
matters like
um
for example like one example of how they
use it so effectively
they are all rushing to save chong son
they get there chong sun sees anjo this
isn't like that oh
a girl but then they notice
namra's bit
and
when it when it comes time to shoot we
kill her should we not and then they're
fighting over it
chong song goes
you're always just taking his side you
know and so it comes back to that
feeling like he really loves her but he
believes
but he he knows that she likes him yeah
so he can't just
say that so that's where the tension and
the dist and the gap between them grows
even more
and it's because of what they planted
with the first episode of the romances
and also like with anja the little
exchanges and look she gives to stud
muffin about you know like whenever she
sees how
he's so dedicated to keeping prez alive
you know so that's what i mean they use
it in subtle ways yeah or sometimes a
funny little bit to do but they don't it
doesn't get bogged down and then like
arguing about it you know well yeah
because you can tell this becomes teen
soap opera for me yeah yeah it's not
taking a break to do something
perfunctory in that moment at least in
the dialogue that was really well
handled because yeah we can tell okay
like part of this is because you have
that piece of knowledge and you are you
know feeling a little hurt
just due to that anyway but also the way
he he at least covers it in that moment
and the piece of logic that he kind of
defines it with is
pertinent to the point where yeah it
doesn't feel cheap it feels like an
actual you know character beat or nuance
of some kind
yeah but [ __ ] anjo's dad
is uh apparently like a freaking action
he's the best
just like that crazy wall hopping he
does
taking out all the special forces guys
i'm like damn
was any of this established at all
before this episode i guess what he said
to the one guy must be true because i
feel like he stepped up to the one guard
at first and he was like oh hey i served
here and the guy's like oh really cool
so i guess i'm like okay you must have
you just knocks them all out yeah yeah
cause yeah she knocks those guys out
pretty early hops that wall handily
oh my god he's so old and he's just a
firefighter
i'm like this must must be a walk in the
parking guys like 20 years old
internally he's at the prime of his life
that song the meditation song about this
is the most beautiful years of our lives
or whatever uh he is in the most
beautiful years of his life it was so
lethal
yeah
yeah but and i liked even those i think
i think actually on uh in the first
episode when she's looking at the
wall i think she sees medals of his okay
if i'm now i think i'm that's coming to
memory right now i could see that as
some kind of search and rescue thing
yeah i don't think i knew what those
medals meant
yeah we can we can go back
i'm pretty confident about i think or
rewards or something i'm pretty sure
that was there
excellence in life-saving abilities
but yeah no i think he was a former hit
man
he's from the continental she's from the
john wick universe
so much more badass than i expected yeah
absolutely i i i i can do with a badass
dad i was bummed he left his buddy
behind and that guy's probably [ __ ]
now i was thinking like how are you
going to cover this
no i mean after seeing what happened
there
yeah it's because i was thinking the
same thing i mean
you know yes he'll get punished he's not
gonna get freaking executed yeah
i don't know maybe maybe i don't know
they like knocked out guards and stole
their clothes and [ __ ] yeah they you
know um
however you know when they're seeing at
that running thing when they're running
away from them at the end like oh that
guy one of them definitely would have
died yeah because there's two of them
once those those shooters are that bad i
can't even hit one out of two running
targets in a straight line yeah that's
the thing is if they had both run then
all of those guys would have caught up
to the other dude and they just all
would have shot him
they would have done
something
like that to really make it that much
more painful but i i liked uh i i liked
the bits of like protocol argument they
had there that finally like pushed him
to that point and the council like i've
enjoyed i expected the thing with the
councilwoman every time
from her first appearance and that
situation and everything that they were
talking about then my initial reaction
was ugh okay so this will probably be
one of those characters where like yeah
like you're mostly just a very blatant
allegory or something but i actually
have enjoyed the way they've drawn
her interplay with him and that in this
episode of her being like hey what are
you doing i told you i would do
everything i can with the protocols just
like you did
uh and at first i was like ah she's like
trying to clap back at him but it seemed
like she really meant that and i like
that it's like okay
we can't wait for the protocols because
i could have saved way more people in
the past based on i wasted that time
waiting on protocols that's a real thing
and i think that they've realized that a
lot with a lot more finesse than i
initially expected and i thought that
was nicely handled here in in the camp
it made those moments count and it's
funny too because you only cut back to
the to the detective guy and the and his
and the baby like like maybe once
or twice and even they like left it
impressed like that's the thing is even
though this was like a return to like
mostly focusing on the kids at school no
matter how brief it was hopping to a
different plot line everybody made an
impression yeah and everything felt
pertinent and important and nothing felt
randomly placed even though
like checking in with the guy in the
paramedic
is a bit you know i feel like it is one
or two scenes but even that it's just
like oh no they got a baby now they got
a child what else are they going to run
in they're going to get like a preteen
next episode
but uh
at least as the build-up with them's
been going and for some level of like
still intensity but also kind of levity
i i enjoyed that as well
all right guys well
uh what we got like six more episodes
ago we're halfway nine ten eleven twelve
yeah
halfway
there my physique is gonna wrap up in
like two episodes i know
that's the crazy thing about the real
time i guess
because i keep having to remind myself
yeah it's only been like two days yeah
you know and they're it's like it's so
good at putting you in the crawl of time
and and not ever
dragging while also making it feel like
we've been here long enough to be
heading into some kind of climax yeah
yeah
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here and uh let's do a page
andrew hayes if there's anyone perfect
for his i mean you have taught us how to
survive the snowpocalypse
you taught us how to survive a totally
different apocalypse who would we want
on our team in a zombie apocalypse it's
gotta be you think of it man think of
all the uses we could make out of a guy
with lock picking skills out of a guy
with muscle but who's also short and
could fit into confined spaces we could
put you up through the walls you could
climb up get us some kind of crucial
piece of tech that we can then bring
back down just in time for you to get
bit but oh no look out andrew's got that
special blood that's right buddy you
would be immune to the virus in this
version of the tail but uh seriously i
hope you're doing well
and i'm pretty sure yeah you've done
this almost the exact same shout out for
andreas on a different zombie thing we
covered i don't believe it
i was like this all sounds insanely
familiar nope and i'm 100 percent
confident there is some other zombies
it's not a mad lib
exact same thing about the apocalypse
stuff and the pick and the locks
if there's anybody i want in the zombie
apocalypse it's not you you've already
stay away
stay away from us you're going to get us
all killed andrew hayes there's
rehashing old material now
never never this is a i dare you to find
it
[Music]
you